alongside the wealth of mega
blockbusters and beloved animated
staples Disney Plus boasts hundreds of
shows and films these include films you
may have loved as a child especially if
you grew up in the 80s and 90s as well
as a host of gems you likely haven't
seen yet for anyone whose adult life
bears little resemblance to the person
you thought you'd be when you grew up
Disney's the kid is for you the kid
follows Russ Duritz
played by Bruce Willis in one of his
rare comedic roles that's completely
free of action Duritz is a jaded image
consultant whose sense of morality
ethics and childlike wonder are all
buried deep beneath his drive for
success at all costs but when a young
boy named rusty shows up uninvited in
his house both are horrified to realize
that they're the same person at
different ages rusty is particularly
disappointed that Russ hasn't fulfilled
any of the hopes and dreams he had for
himself as a child predictably Russ and
rusty go on to learn valuable lessons
from each other throughout the kid and
each comes out of their magical
encounter better than when they began
but although there's a lot to appreciate
here thematically the main reason to
watch the kid is for the enchanting
chemistry between Willis and his younger
counterparts Spencer Breslin who played
wonderfully off each other and do a
great job of convincing us that they're
the same person 40 in a couple days
that it's especially fun to watch their
shared mannerisms and expressions and
their reactions to discovering they have
the same weird habits and tics the 90s
were a golden age for high concept
comedies
case in point Sister Act the story of a
rough-around-the-edges Reno nightclub
singer who goes into hiding in a San
Francisco convent after witnessing a
murder and winds up revitalizing the
nuns struggling choir in the process
Whoopi Goldberg stars as Dolores who
assumes the identity of reluctant nun
sister Mary Clarence she's joined by
Harry Potter's own Maggie Smith as the
Reverend Mother and Harvey Keitel as
Dolores his murderous ex-boyfriend Vince
with an incredible supporting cast
rounding out the colorful choir members
the story of Dolores hiding out in the
convent choir and bonding with the
community of nuns is amusing enough but
what really elevates Sister Act are the
songs not only does the lorises presence
inject new vitality into the music the
choir performs but she also live-ins up
both the singers and the church itself
drawing in new parishioners who are
curious about the energetic music
they've heard drifting out of the
sanctuary doors thanks to its enduring
characters and toe-tapping Tunes Sister
Act was successful enough to inspire an
entertaining 1993 sequel that's also on
Disney Plus and a third in the works for
the streaming platform if what you're
looking for most in a new streaming
service are heartwarming stories of
friendship between humans and dogs look
no further than the 1991 historical
adventure White Fang based on Jack
London's 1906 novel White Fang is the
story of young explorer Jack Conroy
played by Ethan Hawke and his unlikely
bond with an orphaned wolf found during
the Klondike Gold Rush over the course
of the film both Jack and White Fang
faced tremendous adversity but together
they're able to rise above their
unfortunate circumstances and form a
bond more valuable than the gold that
motivates most of the other characters
in the film White Fang is one of the
more understated films on this list
despite the bear attacks and brutal
dogfights it's mostly a quiet
contemplative tale of kindness
overcoming violence and the tremendous
value of a friend who truly understands
you whether you're a sucker for heroic
dog movies or just someone who enjoys a
strong story of unlikely friendship
White Fang is a lovely film
filled with beautiful snow-covered
scenery and featuring a
characteristically understated heartfelt
performance from ethan hawke before Tony
start to build his first Ironman suit
before Captain America emerged from the
ice Disney gave us a different type of
superhero in The Rocketeer the soaring
tale set in 1938 and based on the
groundbreaking comic by writer artist
Dave Stephens follows bill Campbell as
cliffs Accord a down-on-his-luck stunt
pilot who stumbles upon a prototype
jetpack the backpack style rocket was
developed by legendary innovator Howard
Hughes but has now attracted the
interest of a group of Nazis who hoped
to duplicate the technology in order to
invade the United States aided by his
girlfriend Jenny and his friend Peavy
cliff uses the rocket to become the
heroic Rocketeer facing off against both
Nazis and American gangsters and a
Hollywood swashbuckler played by a
scenery-chewing former James Bond
Timothy Dalton spy saboteur
fascist
all of the above although The Rocketeer
predates the MCU by nearly two decades
it contains everything we've come to
expect from a modern day superhero
blockbuster there's the thrilling
montage of cliff testing the rocket and
fine-tuning his powers a cast of
larger-than-life villains a sweeping
score big fights that culminate in even
bigger explosions and even the inclusion
of a couple of oscar-winning actors in
alan arkin and jennifer connelly
whether you've already worked your way
through disney pluses extensive Marvel
catalog or just want a superhero flick
without the complicated universe The
Rocketeer is sure to fit the bill more
than three decades after the film's
initial release Who Framed Roger Rabbit
still remains a marvel of filmmaking
seamlessly blending classic hand-drawn
animation with a hard-boiled live-action
mystery to this day few other movies
have even attempted so ambitious of
fusion and it's pretty easy to argue
that none have done it as successfully
as Roger Rabbit the film follows
detective Eddie valiant played by Bob
Hoskins an alcoholic private
investigator who's developed an intense
hatred of tooms ever since one killed
his brother initially hired by the head
of a major cartoon studio to dig up dirt
on the wife of Roger Rabbit the studio's
biggest tune star Eddie finds himself
caught up in a real-life murder
investigation when Roger is accused of
killing his wife's lover on paper it
doesn't sound like the plot of a movie
for kids but somehow the film's
inclusion of its tuned characters make
it work characters are killed by falling
safes and pianos adultery is emphasized
through exuberant games of pattycake and
while it has a whole lot of grisly
violence in the form of slowly
dissolving characters alive in vats of
acid it's mostly directed at the toons
it's a little scary for younger viewers
but in a fun and thrilling way while
also giving adults plenty to enjoy in
merging multiple genres and techniques
that seemingly have no business going
together Who Framed Roger Rabbit manages
to be a film that is not just innovative
but also hilarious surprising and wholly
appealing to audiences of any age
although it may come off as a little
cheesy these days in the 80s flight of
the navigator was the ultimate in
preteen wish-fulfillment
while walking through the woods to pick
up his hated younger brother 12-year old
David gets abducted by aliens when he
returns he discovers that in the minutes
he was gone eight years have passed and
now he's the only one who can save a
spaceship full of weird and lovable
aliens not only does David get to save
his new friends and pilot in awesome
spaceship but he also learns to
appreciate his now older brother who
irritated him so much at the beginning
of the movie enabling him to mend their
relationship when he eventually returns
to his time although some of the very
early CGI special effects that seemed so
impressive to kids in the 80s
understandably haven't aged particularly
well the story and the irresistible
acute alien still hold up as a
light-hearted all filled adventure plus
you get to see a young Sarah Jessica
Parker as a sympathetic NASA intern and
Paul Reubens aka pee-wee Herman as the
voice of Max the sentient alien
spaceship flight of the navigator is an
exciting and entertaining romp through
time and space it may not actually
transport viewers back to their
childhoods but it can at least remind us
all of the fun and wonder of being a kid
1939 s The Wizard of Oz is one of the
all-time cinema classics but it's much
darker 1985 sequel Return to Oz is far
less well known it's grim right from the
opening moments as we see Dorothy Gale
committed to a mental asylum six months
after the tornado that sent her to Oz in
order to treat her persistent
hallucinations of that far away world
however before Dorothy can receive her
terrifying shock therapy the asylum is
struck by lightning and Dorothy escapes
after falling into a river and nearly
drowning because this girl just can't
catch a break
Dorothy awakens at us but it's not the
Oz she remembers the yellow brick road
is broken and overgrown the Emerald City
has been destroyed by the rock
controlling Nome King and a headless
witch named mombi is ruling over what
remains
we even see the Tin Man and Cowardly
Lion transformed into stone statues much
like Dorothy's original trip to Oz she
gradually assembles an eclectic group of
fantastical allies to help her in her
quest to overthrow mombi defeat the Nome
King and return Ozma the rightful ruler
of Oz to the throne unlike the original
Wizard of Oz returned to us has no
cheerful songs to sing along with and it
treats much of the original film's
lightheartedness and innocence for a
more somber take on the magical land
over the rainbow while there's plenty of
Nightmare fuel for little kids older
viewers will be thrilled by the
imaginative fresh and very
take on the world we all thought we knew
that knobs and broomsticks is often
compared to the far more successful Mary
Poppins and for good reason but it's
more than entertaining enough to stand
on its own the film follows a group of
siblings who are evacuated during the
Blitz into the care of Miss price played
by Angela Lansbury the kids quickly find
out that miss price is actually an
aspiring witch who is teaching herself
magic via a correspondence course
in the hopes of using what she learns to
help the British war effort she trades
the children a magical bed knob in
exchange for their promise to keep her
secret but they soon wind up on a
psychedelic journey to London together
in pursuit of her final spell once there
the children and miss price find
themselves wrapped up in a magical
musical adventure that takes them into
fantasy worlds populated by animated
creatures it's a sweet and charming
escapade filled with memorable songs and
beautiful animated sequences instead of
being a simple attempt to recreate the
success of Mary Poppins it feels more
like a spiritual sequel that's sure to
put a smile on the face of anyone in
search of a little magic there have been
a whole lot of films adapting the three
musketeers over the years in fact Disney
Plus alone has three of them to choose
from the most fun by far is the 1993
live-action take on the classic
adventure novel which stars Kiefer
Sutherland Oliver Platt and Charlie
Sheen as the Musketeers with Chris
O'Donnell as young up-and-comer
d'Artagnan the film follows d'Artagnan
as he heads to Paris in order to join
the Kings Musketeers only to find the
Musketeers disbanded by the order of the
sinister Cardinal Richelieu a
fantastically slimy role for the iconic
Tim Curry what noble business brings you
here I came to join the Kings Musketeers
I mean the Cardinal plans to assassinate
the king and seize the throne for
himself so d'Artagnan winds up joining
forces with three musketeers who refuse
the order to disband to save the kingdom
while every iteration of the three
musketeers has been jam-packed full of
high stakes adventure and swashbuckling
action Disney script infuses the classic
tale with the generous dose of humor to
go along with it you come in peacefully
intend to resist I don't be stupid of
course we tend to resist give us a
moment all right check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]